right to my next guest and all of this
national border patrol council president
brandon judd brandon you know we've had
this conversation now for so long you
and i uh but this twist that um that
bill referred to single adult grown men
supposed to be expelled back instead of
being put on put into taxis onto planes
and dispersed around the country how do
you explain that
you can't explain it but that's what
that's why we know that this crisis
isn't going away you alluded already
that we've already apprehended
more people in this month of december
than we had the past three decembers
combined
that is scary to me because december is
normally our slowest month of the year
and when we have when we apprehend 178
000 people what that's showing is that
it's overwhelming all resources not just
cbp's resources but isis resources so
when i take somebody into custody and i
process them i process them for
deportation i then turn them over to ice
ice can either hold them in custody
pending that deportation proceeding or
they can release them with the
expectation that they're going to show
up for their court proceedings but when
ice gets overwhelmed when ice doesn't
have
the space to hold these people that's
when they start releasing them and
that's what we start seeing but what
really upsets me about this is the the
administration hides this from everybody
they don't tell anybody how many people
ice are releasing they show how many
people cbp is releasing but they don't
show they don't show how many people ice
are releasing and that's where the
hidden number comes in and that's where
all those hundreds of thousands of
people in fiscal year 21 they were
released from isis custody not
necessarily cbps yeah and you could see
advice is overwhelmed and they sent them
back or i you know but to put them on
planes and and distribute uh folks
around the country brandon we got to
leave it there thank you so much my
friend i'm steve ducey i'm brian kill me
and i'm ainsley earhart and click here
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis